♪♪
[ Electricity buzzing ]
-You are not beloved
by Donald Trump.
The president is not a fan.
-Are you suggesting
that we're not getting along?
Because of our 67 lawsuits?
[ Laughter ]
-"How am I gonna get famous?"
-"Get outta here!"
-Avocado, guacamole.
-"I'll blast ya.
I'll blast ya for free."
[ Laughter ]
-"Why would you do this to me?!"
-[Chattering]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-There's one very specific thing
Donald Trump loves doing,
and that's showing off
pieces of paper.
He's done it multiple times
with letters from world leaders,
supposedly secret deals
with other countries,
and just last week,
he did it again when he held up
newspaper headlines
showing off his acquittal
at two separate events.
I think I know what's
going on here.
Trump's desperate to prove to us
that he knows how to read,
except no one's buying it.
I mean,
when your dog carries
the paper into the house,
no one thinks, "Wow!
He must be
really up to date
on current events."
[ Laughter ]
The Iowa Democratic Party
is having trouble
keeping things together.
In some cases,
together literally.
The chair of the Iowa Party held
a press conference on Monday
to update the media on the
results, and this happened.
-The sheets are signed,
not only by the precinct chair
and the precinct secretary --
[ Clattering ]
[ Laughter ]
Uh.
-Oh, man.
Did you use an app
for your podium, as well?
[ Laughter ]
Was the app called Metaphor?
There's something
I can't believe.
-Tell me.
-What?
-That you two had not met,
not once, before this film.
-That is correct.
-That is shocking.
-Hadn't even run
into each other, ever.
-I mean, I know
I've met both of you,
and I'm a C-lister,
compared to the two of you.
-Correct!
-How could I have met
[ Laughter ]
both of you?
-I knew where you lived
for the longest time.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, really?
-Yeah. Oh, yeah.
-Now, how'd you come about that?
-How did you know where I lived?
-Well, I just sit in my car.
I go, "Ah,
just ring the doorbell.
Just do it. Just do it.
[ Laughter ]
No!
That's gonna be weird. Ah!"
So, that was like
-I see.
-six years of that.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
I knew that
if I was gonna do drag
and make it to above
14th Street, so to speak,
I had to calculate the image.
And then, I took --
And this is scientific.
I took the subversive sexuality
out of my persona
so that Betty and Joe Beercan
could invite me
into their living room.
And you know what?
It worked!
-It worked.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Vice President Biden,
be honest.
When's the last time
you smoked a doob?
-I took a hit in Iowa,
[ Laughter ]
and I'll probably
take a hit here.
-My man!
[ Laughter and applause ]
You were in "The Mandalorian."
We had bikes that were like
on hydraulics
and I punched Baby Yoda.
-You did.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like people
might think that's a joke,
but in the scene,
you really did punch Baby Yoda.
-Yes.
And I can't stress
this enough --
the scene called for it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-The first time I did it,
I hit it like too hard.
And like 30 people popped up,
like moles in that game
that you hit.
And everyone was like, "Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
Whoa! Whoa! Whoa!"
And I went back and like
everyone was really awkward
because I had like
potentially ruined
a billion-dollar franchise.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So like no one
was saying anything
and so like [chuckle] before
I got on my like hover bike,
I went, "I just want
everyone to know
that the Baby Yoda did say
something anti-Semitic to me."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Mayor Buttigieg,
what do you call your fists?
-Murder and mayhem.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I heard that you found out there
was an adult film parody
of "Homeland."
-Um, yeah.
-Wow, congratulations.
-Well, yeah.
I thought "Mad" magazine
was cool.
"SNL" was cool.
But like a porn?
-Yeah. You've made it.
-You know your work
has resonated.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-What was it called?
Do you remember?
-I don't know!
I don't know.
And I don't think it was
very impressive.
-Yeah, it wasn't like
a good --
It wasn't like "Boneland"?
-No.
No! No!
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A new profile has been published
about the rising number
of doctors
using the social media
app TikTok
to talk to teens about health.
Unfortunately, also,
to give diagnoses.
[ Hip hop plays ]
♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
Did you know right away you
wanted Jose for this episode?
-I've been trying
for three of four years --
[ Laughter ]
I mean, he --
Let me tell you, people.
He needed --
-Are you okay if Jose answers?
[ Laughter ]
-He needed a translator.
I was his official translator
because his English
is kind of so-so.
[ Laughter ]
You're very hard to follow.
-Yes.
-Whereas, Jose, I'm with
-It's every word.
-every step of the way.
[ Laughter ]
-Senator Klobuchar, complete
this lyric from 2 Live Crew:
"Face down, ass up..."
-That is the best way to do it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You sort of think
that mediocrity is overlooked.
-Yeah. Why does everything
have to be so good?!
-Yeah.
-You know, Beyoncé,
Einstein, the Muppets, Japan!
I adore a two-star experience.
-Yeah, you know, maybe mediocre
people are watching tonight,
not that I think you are, but,
thank your for your service.
♪♪
[ Electricity buzzing ]